low frequency sounds of the sort that
your voice is that late night FM DJ
voice are responded to in the brain by
neurons no surprise there but the
frequency that those neurons fire is
also low frequency in other words when
you speak in your low voice right the
other person's brain hears that and
starts firing in a low frequency tone in
other words it entrains to your voice
not just the timing but it's actually
like you're essentially playing an
emotional piano down in the low keys of
their all right of their mind now when
you go up to the high frequencies the
neurons can't follow that high frequency
so there's something special about lowf
frequency sound that actually changes
the emotional tone of the people that
hear that low frequency sound